quiero que me ayuden levantando la mano
todas las personas que tienen un pasado
para todos tenemos un pasado déjenlo
arriba todas las personas que tienen un
pasado que duele
qué lástima que enoja y que
probablemente dentro de ese pasado
existe un momento en este pico en el que
te gustaría regresar y cambiar la
situación cuántos
hace unos días leí una frase que decía
la vida no se trata de averiguar quiénes
somos sino de determinar en quién
quieres llegar a ser pero yo creo que
para determinar en quién te quieres
convertir
si necesitas conocer tu pasado si
necesita saber de dónde vienes quién
eres y cuál es tu historia
todos tenemos un pasado quedó a lesión
ya lo vimos cuando lanzamos las semanas
lo malo es que en lugar de recordar como
salimos victoriosos de ese momento
nos ponemos bonitos y entonces empezamos
a cargar con piedras
con piedras donde cada una de ellas
representa un dolor donde representa una
etiqueta que te marcó y vamos con un
costal no que el millón más que cosas
parece itacate pero en lugar de comida
porque traigo piedras
como piedras como el miedo
piedras como la angustia que va a ser de
mi mañana piedras
como la baja autoestima estoy gorda
estoy delgada como la de la pantalla
y entonces pareciera que es requisito
cargar con ese costal todos los días
porque pues ya me voy al animal ya buen
trabajo jefa y justo antes de dar el
paso para salir entonces corres
correspondencia de asma y no te basta
con el peso que llevas todos los días le
echas tu angustia y miedo y si no puedo
y si no llego tu baja autoestima
miami como se fijan en mí micros y
entonces ya llevas tu mochila y te vas a
ir en el camión no y no te vas con todo
lo que cargas
y caldas
quien de ustedes me dice o se levanta
ahorita y se viene aquí conmigo al
frente
y cargas de costal y se da tres vueltas
aquí al complejo y de rapidito
la verdad no imposible pero qué crees
lo chistoso
es que no te lo tengo que pedir ya lo
haces ya cargas con ese costal todos los
días
quiero que te imagines ahorita una línea
y esa va a ser tu línea del tiempo
y vamos a dividir esta línea de 10 en
días para llegar a este naciste
obviamente tenía 20 años
efe
tenía 0 años después pasaste y cumplirse
llega hasta los 30
y este también porque no me está dando
una vez llega hasta tu etapa 2030 y si
bien nos va llegaremos a los 80
así echando mejoras o no hoy la mayoría
de nosotros estamos parados en los
veintes cuantos tienen 20 saca
veintitantos aguas y la mayoría ya
vivimos dos décadas dos décadas donde en
la vida de cualquier persona son los
años más importantes porque es donde
creamos identidad autoestima
donde tenemos que tomar decisiones
importantes y una de ellas es la
elección de carrera cuántos de ustedes
salen para nos tierra sí claro pero
entonces la presión sociales que visitó
ahorita es porque te vas a dedicar y
justo cuando tienes que tomar la
decisión no sabes si quieres ser doctor
abogado lo que quieras y entonces tomas
la primera decisión que se te viene a la
mente o la que tus papás o las personas
que te rodean te dijeron eso porque pues
a eso se dedica la familia porque si no
de que el artista hijo vete de abogado
pero por qué
porque tenemos que permitir que las
personas tomen decisiones sobre nosotros
a cuantos adultos no conoces que viven
frustrados haciendo un trabajo que no
les gusta que no les llena que no les
apasiona
que las ganas de encontrar tu pasión son
más grandes que tu miedo al qué dirán
hace
unos años no muchos
yo siempre viví en expectativa
querer agradar a los demás y empecé a
cargar piedras que no me correspondían
y llega un momento en el que te cansas
en el que te agotas
te levantas y te ves al espejo y no te
reconoces
y entonces te preguntas quién eres y
saben qué es lo más triste
que no tiene respuesta a esa pregunta
pero para llegar a ella yo tuve que
salir de mi zona de confort tuve que
moverme
y sigue sin funcionar
y
y tuve que moverme durante un año tuve
que alejarme de mi familia tuve que
vivir en un lugar donde el español no se
habla
lave trastes talle pisos
limpia paredes
aquí necesitan algo pues aquí estoy
claro pero que creen hace un momento
tuve mi recompensa
reconocí que soy bueno en lo que hago
porque no es el puesto es la actitud me
di cuenta que tengo la capacidad de
hacer que las cosas sucedan
y qué creen me di cuenta que siendo yo
misma me caía bien a la gente cuando era
lo contrario que tenía que fingir ser
alguien que no era para agradar a los
demás
ubica tu línea de tiempo
esto no me sirven este si ya me
desespero ubica tu link donde estás
parado ahorita
reflexiona qué decisiones tuviste que
tomar para llegar hoy aquí
y ahora me hace el futuro
qué decisiones tienes que tomar para
llegar a donde tú quieres estar
estos últimos días pues súper nerviosa
preocupada porque hablar de un tema que
tenga que ver con el empoderamiento de
la mujer dios es un reto y entonces me
puse a investigar
y se preguntas a hombres y mujeres y me
pregunta de investigación siempre fue
cual creen que es el mayor reto de una
mujer mujeres aquí presentes cual
quieren que sea nuestro mayor reto
la mayoría me contestó su mayor reto es
creer en ellas mismas me encanta lo que
uno elijo y lo cito estaba aquí en la
diapositiva
su mayor reto podría ser saberse dueña
de su vida
creer en ellas
saber ser dueñas de tu vida creer en ti
cuántas veces no te has quedado con las
ganas de intentar algo nuevo es decir yo
puedo yo voy pero que basta un
comentario negativo o un pensamiento
destructivo para decir no no puedo y
espérame tantito hombres cuántos de
ustedes aquí presentes se identifican
con estas preguntas
me di cuenta que para hablar
empoderamiento de la mujer una cita de
hablar del rol del hombre en nuestras
vidas
porque a diferencia de nosotras los
hombres no tienen tanta libertad de
expresar sus emociones sus sentimientos
a poco me han escuchado la frase los
hombres no lloran
que las mujeres pues viviendo
discriminación por el simple hecho de
ser mujeres si duele si ida por aje si
te molesta si pero sabes que más molesta
mujer que la primera discriminación
viene de ti misma cuando te dices no
puedo no soy suficiente no soy capaz y
después fue hecho este rato que quiera
porque típico alguien andrea andrea qué
guapo estás qué chula qué bonita oye me
encanta tu bolsa pero se va andrea y yo
a la vista gorda se ve que descuidada y
esto que va allí y eso que se cuida
sí o no los hombres por lo menos se
dicen las cosas de siempre y tan amigos
como siempre
y alguien con esto nuestro aplauda más
al hombre no
mujer date cuenta del valor que tienes
por el simple hecho de ser mujer
los hombres nos admiran los hombres nos
admiran
me dijeron vale las mujeres son el
centro y equilibrio de nosotros claro
claro que somos el centro y equilibró de
ellos hoy aplaude
aplastante porque eres una mujer de
éxito
de valor
cuando yo estaba ensayando yo tenía una
detrás de cada uno de un hombre con
sueño hay una mujer con visión y esta
misma persona me dijo en una me dijo no
me ley no está atrás de cada hombre es
al lado de cada hombre hay una mujer con
visión somos un equipo somos parte de un
sistema y como sistema tenemos que
trabajar juntos para crecer juntos
mujer en verdad aplaude te aplaude te
porque eres sinónimo de éxito compromiso
entrega pasión vida
y sabes quién es tu mayor referente de
éxito desde mujer quién crees que sea tu
mayor éxito por ejemplo de mayor éxito
tu mamá
tu mamá es tu mayor referente de éxito
cuántas y cuántas de ustedes su mamá no
tuvo que renunciar a sus sueños por
cumplir las expectativas de sus papás o
probablemente dejó al lado su vida
personal por ayudarte a cumplir tus
metas o probablemente en casos muy
extremos tu mamá dio la vida
mi mamá dejó al lado sus sueños ella
quería ser azafata viajar por el mundo y
mi abuela le dijo no mi hijita está
terminando la secundaria te vas para
estudiar para secretaria
y terminando va a entrar esta empresa
probablemente tu mamá y mi mamá
no tuvieron una opción pero qué crees tú
si la tienes tú si tienes la opción de
ganarte el derecho a hablar alzar la voz
prepárense y estar segura de lo que eres
te decía de lalín a tiempo
ya no la veas como una línea recta ahora
vela como en ascenso
estas diapositivas ahora
de las como unas líneas de ascenso
y fíjate muy bien en los pasos que
tienes que ir dando para llegar al
objetivo porque vas a llegar pide y se
te dará
si te diste cuenta
aquí aquí estoy estoy triste cuenta y
hoy no viene hablar de mi historia
y hoy vine a recordarte que tú tienes
una historia que contar y así como hoy
estoy yo aquí parada
tú también podrías estar lo aquí
porque eres ya digno de admirar lo digno
de escuchar
y todos merecemos una vez en la vida que
nos habla bien que nos aplaudan porque
tu historia cuenta
solamente necesitas cambiar la manera en
la que ves las cosas dentro de tu costal
dentro de tu inta cate hay piedras en
bruto
pero qué crees también existen las
piedras preciosas los diamantes
solo que estos necesitan de trabajo
necesita pulirse
crea pensamientos positivos y da pasos
de fe
no olvides tu pasado no olvides tus
raíces no olvides de dónde vienes
deja ya las guerras en bruto a un lado
en una esquina donde no te estorben
quiero que ahorita por favor recuerden
un momento y ahora recuérdalo con todas
las ganas en el que te sentiste amado
querido valorado en el que dijiste si lo
logré tras el examen de la guata
[Música]
micros
y donde mayor logro no sienten momentos
de adentro
a nivel del corazón te dice si no
manches
cambia la manera en la que ves las cosas
y vas a cargar un costal de piedras que
sean piedras preciosas gracias
[Aplausos]